[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
welcome back to the break room those
those tips and tool man taylor sounds
mean we're rolling live
from the new rockstars headquarters here
this is the nerdy news show that brings
you all the stuff you need to know um
coming up today we'll be talking some
she-hulk news in bulk
uh deadpool 3 update disney plus takes
home some hardware
also did
harry styles spit on christmas time
got it normally you gotta pay for that
hey yo
uh but with me here today to talk about
those topics and more we got mr brandon
barrack oh hello how's everyone doing uh
they're good the the wonderful angelica
[Applause]
you tried to extort me but at the end of
the day i'm back
tom to maximoff is here for all her
babies
how are you doing keep it gucci to
moochie it's positive tuesday
very positive tuesday tip top tuesday
keeping it gucci to moochie as always
thank you tommy uh
on today's chat we already appreciate
the folks uh shouting out in the chat
mezzo jd we see you alex reyes everybody
uh if you decide to throw us a couple of
doubloons in the chat a we're gonna try
to read any questions folks throw out
today any other super chats uh no matter
how disgusting and debased
well we expect that from you are you
trying to force oh disgusting
labor day means that most of our
hard-working
uh american workforce was able to take
the day off yesterday which means the
streets and the chats are littered with
trash oh my gosh nothing's clean
everything's dirty and we get it all you
trash bags are in there counting your
labor day gambling winnings from your
back alley dice games and god knows what
else you've done for money this weekend
you filthy filthy garbage bags so give
it to us
time to turn it over to us give me your
money that's right every hundred dollars
we uh make in super chats we will be
spinning the redemption wheel which you
can see over tommy and angelica's
shoulder there's a lot of fun things on
there including something related to uh
don't worry darling
the scandalous uh olivia wilde harry
styles it's been a wild weekend
olivia wilde weekend and my sources say
that movie is beautiful
it's a good one
florence beautiful
[Music]
let's hop into some headlines oh baby
yes
also just real quick it is uh there's a
heat wave oh my god graveyard look me in
there uh coming through look me in the
eye while you do it
indeed graveyard wow uh
thank you so much um
uh it is hot in the studio right now
there's a heat wave in los angeles our
poor little
it's a good eye contact
we're going to explain these bowls later
please don't explain it or never explain
it uh but it is hot so we look a little
parched a little washed out a little
damp uh it's both because we're so
invested in this show and because it's
it's 86 degrees we are yeah we're
absolutely excreting from our from our
from our [ __ ] threats
to our wets okay my gosh
from our speakers to our squeakers
and our
sneakers oh my god all the way all the
way down to the sneakers okay it's it's
it's a hot one okay
name callers to our shame fallers oh my
gosh oh the crown on down
from the
but we do we do have to spin the wheel
for uh um graveyard here uh but let me
i'll read the first headline then we'll
spin the wheel
the most recent episode of she-hulk we
learned that wang enjoyed a years-long
career at target they briefly showed his
linkedin profile you can see that he
used to work at target before becoming
source for supreme uh showrunner jessica
gao
has given credit to the graphics team
for that fun little easter egg she said
uh she had to give credit to our
graphics team i may be mistaken but
probably only at well is the one that
came up with that that must be somebody
in the graphics department oh only oh
he's such a trickster could be it could
be a she we don't know i don't know the
normal gender of an only it's definitely
a mirror because it's so funny
okay
male emojis in the chat for all the
comedies
your hyenas should have continued okay
i hate this
i was fighting for my legal life
i was in the courts the canadian courts
hiatus he hardly knew us okay
all right um there's more to the quote
but uh that's the gist of it what's
funny about that
it said he worked at target and john and
i produced john and i looked at this it
was it said at commer times like the
target at comartaj which kamataj is the
name of the temple which is in kathmandu
yes nepal so it's very funny to think
that there must be a target like how
sometimes there's a starbucks inside a
target yes or there's a mcdonald's
inside a walmart yeah they had a secret
taj is leasing out some of its space to
target probably a city target i would
assume there are vending machines inside
uh maximum security prisons as well
what does that have to do with that
things inside of things
from rochester new york the bills make
they want wanna shout two more days okay
real quick are we sure that it's the uh
um chain department store that we are
familiar with
and not like he was just working at the
target for nine years nine years
he's trying to he's trying to
bump up his linkedin profile yeah
what was the rule what did it say
exactly again it said retails
okay so maybe that does kind of maybe it
was
[Music]
[Applause]
he was retailing we got to retell him
again oh he's like eeyore rental
okay i think we should spin the
redemption wheel uh thank you
knick-knack zach braddock like that
first name zach uh and of course uh
graveyard depraved gourd
uh here i'll spin it now now we do if
you can see we do have chris pines some
would argue the best chris maybe maybe
right now the best chris maybe one of
the top two chris is in the middle there
due to his uh appearing and don't worry
darling there's all kinds of crazy stuff
we're not gonna read all the different
redemptions i'm just gonna spin it see
where it falls
and i will commit to doing whatever it
is
oh silly string oh you got the worst one
is it is it silly stringed or silly
strung okay i'm gonna get i'm against
the board the firing uh squad board here
tommy is gonna do his one out of the way
oh no he's got both cans and silly
string okay
uh not the face kneel and beg four
not the fans no
i agree with everything you said
but you killed my mother
oh god
oh no okay that's gonna set well yeah
that's gonna melt on you yeah that's
good okay again 86 degrees in the studio
this is uh well worth it
that was you got me good tommy oh my
chair it wasn't me i didn't want to do
it it's in his mouth the wheel mandated
that we had to uh it's in his bowl his
water bottle oh that's the wheel it's
some would say i'm silly stringed from
my router to my tutor
yeah oh that was a really it was a
really wet silly string yeah well i did
i pre-licked it before i came in
okay ah here brandon can you cover the
next headline here while i'll take it
yeah yeah i haven't done a headline in a
while headline the direct gave us a look
behind the scenes at the she-hulk and
megan v stallion twerk scene i believe
we have an asset here we can actually
see the actress uh who plays uh she-hulk
tatiana maslany tatiana
uh in a mocap suit yes i do think it's
funny that she actually did it yeah i
like that it was she went in and did the
performance brandon so good i would want
to do it too absolutely yeah she said
that she's a huge fan of megan the
stallion and it was like the highlight
of the story
i was a highlight to both meet her and
get to do a scene where also brandon
pointed out like you really get a sense
of like techno mazlane is a very small
person they have her like on a a pretty
significant lift and she's still about
the same height as megan the style the
stallion
um oh also uh speaking with the direct
marina bacarin uh who you'll know from a
lot of stuff including uh firefly
firefly um the first season of um
homeland homeland yeah awesome and um
pertinent to this headline deadpool 1
and deadpool 2. i was asked if she would
be returning to deadpool 3 and here was
her quote you know from your lips to
god's ears i have no idea they're
writing the script right now i'm usually
the last to find out anything i wish i
had information i could give you but i
really don't but it would be great which
is an interesting uh variation on our
thirsty thespian yeah format she's still
a little thirsty she would love to
appear in it but i think that was like a
uh
snacking screen actors guild yeah
actress like it was like she was just a
little
little taste in her mouth
uh but nice now we've heard this before
but nice again to get confirmation they
are writing it yeah they're writing it
they're writing it as we speak
um the
creative arts emmys took place over the
weekend uh and chadwick boseman won a
posthumous emmy for his voice work on
what if mm-hmm which how nice that he's
doing a great job voicing uh t'challa in
those episodes totally um also picking
up some awards both moon knight and book
of boba fett won some emmys uh for
outstanding sound editing and
outstanding special visual effects
respectively yeah
good work guys good work good yeah
and good work on uh for tim robinson i
think you should leave winning at me
rick and morty i believe won some emmys
let's talk about the
the true triumph of the evening best
television movie going to chip and dale
rescue rangers that's
what an achievement that wasn't a
headline strange that it counts as a
television movie yeah it is weird it
didn't come out in theaters i guess yeah
i know i guess if it has no theatrical
release at all but it joins like
lonesome dove and like
a seriously stacked like uh list of
really good uh television films
which i like chipping down rescue
rangers it's very cute i believe it
should win an oscar i think oh wow oh it
might be that's awesome
all the way up yeah yeah the tomskers
you're putting it ahead don't worry
darling don't worry darling is a sleeper
to win uh and my whoopsie daisy awards
that come out every march
that's when we celebrate uh things we
didn't see coming is that your hasty
pudding society or whatever yeah
oh that movie whoops a daisy
so hopefully the show's still going on
in march and we can do those okay uh
ahead of uh disney plus day on september
8th which again we're going to be
covering that that's this thursday we're
anticipating getting a lot of good uh
news maybe some trailers some casting
announcements of uh future disney plus
properties there's this big room where
we're gonna get a secret invasion
trailer possibly thursday maybe not till
saturday but ahead of that and we also
know that's when um
thor love thunder is going to be
released on disney plus for streaming um
ahead of that they released another
deleted scene with jane thor and zeus
you can see that on disney's youtube or
twitter if you would like to go watch
that it's riveting check it out it's
like thor and jane in the hospital zeus
is there which is very weird because
it's so totally different
from him killing zeus so i don't know i
don't know when the decision to kill
zeus came in let's put that spoiler
banner up real quick
that movie only came out three months
ago
are people saying spoilers
you're saying the idea of killing zeus
and spoilers even though we also know in
the end credit scene he is confirmed to
still be
yeah okay this is kind of a nonsense
from a zeus to a snooze
which one's the zeus
it's up to you they're both like a chloe
on the latest episode of the ringers
entertainment podcast the town justin
kroll a reporter at deadline which is
usually like a great source for breaking
scoops things like that they're like
legitimate journalists over a deadline
for the most part i was discussing kind
of the upcoming films of florence pugh
speaking of which uh
don't worry darling star uh and he
mentions the thunderbolts and when
talking about the film he described it
as florence florence's character yolanda
belova leading a team that includes
wyatt russell's u.s agent john walker
and daniel bruhl's baron zemo now he
could have been just kind of quoting the
thing that lots of us are assuming that
that might be the lineup and like
guessing that she's going to be in it
and yada yada yeah but or he knows
something as an entertainment journalist
they're both confirming those people are
going to be in the thunderbolts movie
and that's like she's the leader of the
life that's the weirdest thing saying
she's the leader which could be true but
i to me i listen to it and it sounds
like if i was explaining the movie to my
mom and i was like yes you got me in
this movie she's gonna be like like i'm
not gonna explain the nuances of like
what the thunder so you're critical you
don't think i don't think it was inside
i don't think he's saying something that
he knows i think he was just explaining
to uh matthew bolani bellamy bellamy uh
like she's in the thunderbolts and she's
leading this team and yeah i don't know
if she's gonna be the leader it would
seem i would think they would make john
walker the lead
i don't know or or val right
i was going to say
sorry an interrupt it's a little bit
like you know obviously the comparisons
are always suicide squad thunderbolts
right it's the a to a
marvel dc comparison but he even says
that on the podcast he does it says it's
essentially like the suicides well he he
should call me because i've been saying
that for years
i've been saying that i came out the
womb screaming that i said hey
my mom was like what the doctor slapped
me across the face and then i cried
never spoke a word again until i was 12.
all right anyway so those are basically
two related things but in the suicide
squad movies you have like uh amanda
waller rick flag then like the will
smith or address elba leader of the
suicide squad character so i mean she
might be the will smith which she in my
opinion is the will smith of movie stars
today anyway but
of the thunderbolts movie she might just
be kind of like the here the hero leader
whereas there are two bureaucratic
leaders above her yeah and it could be
interesting like
we don't know anything about that film
yet including what characters are going
to come in and who's going to be cast
but like could be like a point of view
kind of choice like maybe she is like
we're kind of seeing this movie through
her eyes more so than zemo or or john
walker or whatever right
and of course this will launch us into
50 more videos on the rockstars channel
guessing the other thunderbolts oh yeah
don't tell her give us give us time
to do more yeah well hopefully we get
some thunderbolts news this weekend at
d23 and maybe then that could lead to
some more productive speculating yeah if
only we were going to d23 wait
but i thought
yes possibly zacky and johnny new
rockstars is going to have a presence at
d23 we're also going to have a presence
here in the studio we're gonna be um
broadcasting live this saturday during
the marvel panel um and then we're also
gonna have some people at the marvel
panel reporting back like if they show
some footage that's not released to the
public we'll be able to um you know
verbatim recall that with our
photographic memories and everything
like that and if you see me you best
come fist bump me and say keep it gucci
to moochie but if you go for a handshake
you get a slap
wow
wow that's right
don't shake we hug or we fist bump
that's
wow well ahead of d23 we have uh disney
plus day coming up on thursday of course
uh and for our main discussion today we
wanted to talk about an interesting
tweet i already saw people in the chat
talking about it disney uh plus posted
uh on their own twitter channel they've
been kind of counting down to disney
plus day
uh and for today it was like we're six
days away or
not for today but for the day that was
six days away they posted a little gif
of hugh jackman as wolverine throwing up
the bone claws we got that asset here
mainly to show like the number six right
it's showing the number six but they use
they also put hashtag x-men okay yeah
what are they gonna do when there's only
one day left well they gotta they got a
one mysterious digit to show for that
one uh
um but everyone's kind of like oh what
does this mean right because the other
the other gifts they've been posting
like they posted like a monster zinc
thing and we know that there's a new
monster zinc uh thing coming out we
obviously know that there's like x-men
97 but they didn't use an animated gif
right if they were promoting that why
use uh hugh jackman as wolverine for the
countdown
is there something else coming down the
pipe that maybe we don't know about
well with the gif i feel like it's could
potentially be like okay yeah it could
be the the x-men series or
or i guess with the addition of the
hashtag it feels a little too
intentional right and there's got to be
something it wasn't x-men 97 it was just
x-men or was it hashtag marvel or
hashtag mcu or something like that right
yeah
there's got to be more i think it's
another origins film another origins i
mean they did use a gift from
wolverine origins i think it's the best
wolverine film they're they're just
getting the best one
some people have been speculating could
this connect to deadpool three yeah
right deadpool famously debuted ryan
rabbit's deadpool debuted in that film
right that's right um there is a
connection there between wolverine and
deadpool of course both being products
of the weapon x program and like hugh
jackman has walked away from wolverine
logan was his like final film it seemed
like and he seemed
to feel that way too
but do you think they could convince old
hugh to come back to the
the claws do we want to see hugh jackman
again as wolverine if they like green
light him
doing like a musical along with they're
like we'll let you do a 300 million
dollar musical give a more creative why
not endeavor why not combine those ideas
let him do a 300 million dollar
wolverine my hands he sort of did at
that
we came to the hollywood bowl a couple
years ago just to do like hugh jackman
okay like he was on a tour of show tunes
let me back in the bowl brian henson
this is going out to you specifically
write a letter on my behalf asking the
bull to let me back oh okay hashtag
tommy goes bowling now here's another
idea i'll throw it to you okay we know
that there's a mutant film
coming out because there was this kind
of leak of like the mutants being
snagged by disney as like a title and we
assume this is like a movie do you think
we could get like a surprise where we're
not we're going to get a sear like a tv
series before we get some sort of mute
i i like this one they've already kind
of the first time the word mutant has
been uttered in the mcu was in a series
in that post-credits scene in miss
martin he said mutation
if they do i mean it seems like that's
kind of the path they're on where
they're kind of almost setting up films
with series now right um
yeah so you're saying because like
especially in phase six we know three
big ones
films yeah we don't know what's filling
the gaps between both the disney plus
series and maybe some other films so
like do you think we would see a series
before a film maybe like a could be an
x-force series maybe
maybe a solo series for somebody like a
storm a jean grey uh a whale they could
definitely do a rogue solo show they
could definitely do a rogue show about
taking on the rogue uh
just like figuring out how to not kill
everyone she touches what's the title of
it going rogue
rogue theory
okay the title is for sale come come see
us thank you come see us uh there we
have some people on the chat like mo
reese pointing out it's possibly it
could be like an eight three eight
wolverine yeah yeah there's obviously
mutants in the 838 yeah uh
uh a lot of people saying like don't
bring him back logan was such like a
nice ending yeah you know you mentioned
deadpool three he could be in deadpool
three just as like a goofy cameo right
he's just sitting at a bar or something
yeah
yeah though it also feels like if
they're still writing deadpool 3 they're
not ready to announce right cameos
all these actors could always be lying
because they're if they say anything
truthful they get in trouble so i feel
like all these anyone in the mcu or mcu
adjacent just lies like a rug in all of
their hey it's called acting you're
right
by the way the show has changed it's now
scooby-doo and rogue on the road called
rogue there we go
hey just one brother
yeah justice for the cancelled scoob
movie yeah
right bro that lady's killing you with
her hands man
[Applause]
we gotta get out of here
it was it was magneto the whole time and
i would have gotten away with it if it
weren't for your damn kids
jace lucas in the chat pointing out what
we all know it's going to be a jubilee
series followed by the jubilee trilogy
confirmed kevin feige announced the
jubilee trilogy already ready for
couple polls we ran um do you think wong
was a model target employee was he doing
good work also i appear to be getting an
allergic reaction from the silicone
my neck will never be the same uh that's
what we get for buying dollar stores uh
i shot him in his neck and his back
but what about the other part he looked
down
it leaked down too is zucci
and mike
i'm
happy first day of school kids
but a lot of kids went to school most
most people thought wang was a great
employee
do you think we'll see vanessa marina
baccarin's character in deadpool 3. a
strong resounding 75 saying yes she is
technically dead in canon right you
brought her back at the end we did bring
her back yes she has died once i guess
right yeah okay um do you think elena
will lead the thunderbolts as the
podcast says or will it be someone else
yes she will lead 55
that's not that's not an overwhelming
majority though it's enough to win
okay enough to carry the election that's
right uh and do you think we'll see a
wolverine series announced at d23 oh my
god oh it's a 50 50. i do not want a
wolverine series no do not don't don't
get it what about it but if it's like
it's called young logan
young it's just the kid from young
sheldon
and he hasn't got his powers yeah it's
ian armitage or whatever his name is
he's just super smart i want if they're
gonna do the if they're gonna do
wolverine at all just give me alpha
flight that's what i want oh interesting
keep it canadian keep him out of the
x-men we got a couple canadian friends
in the chat who sometimes throw up uh
canadian dollars that's what i'm about i
recently spent a wonderful morning at
fan expo canada it was great i i
recommend it to anyone toronto canada
did you see some friends i did you know
i saw i got some waves i got some yells
nobody approached me i think because i
was i looked very hungover oh i think
they were like that's a haggard man
i got a new rock star someone yelled
eric vos at me which i did not like i
called the mount i called the mounted
patrol i had them escorted out as you
should uh but then i also got to see um
uh the guy who played
joseph quinn eddie munson i walked right
past him
let me tell you that that was nice
is he he's he's not a canadian he's an
english person right yes but he was
there signing autographs good for him or
look alike at least good for him man i
look alike
good enough to fool tommy
oh wait a second yeah he was
skateboarding he looked pretty awesome i
think it was joseph um real quick okay
so you might have noticed we've been
drinking out of bowls what um here now
partly because it is hot in the studio
and we need to be able to
uh quench our thirst in a in a bowl type
way and also because uh mine used to be
a fish tank but uh also we recently got
rid of all of the mugs that's right in
the overnight
yes because impending
as of later this week we are getting
official break room mugs whoa they will
be for sale on newrockstarsmerch.com
they will be displayed on our table
where we will drink out of them heartily
and i've got a very good idea of exactly
what they should look like so do not
worry everyone will be getting the
official tommy bech told break room mugs
giant image of my face right where you
put your lips this is so this is
disputed okay tommy and i both have
competing designs
um fingers crossed i like that you're
calling yours a design because i call it
an abomination
but not to be confused with emil blonsky
i thought that was a reference no no no
no it's a uh it's a war crime what he
did when he sketched us it's
something that will make children shriek
out anyways oh my god mug weekly says
[Laughter]
what kind of news they cover in month
weekly i stopped mostly mug shots
mug weekly went too woke for me
i mean it has anything to do with faces
too if you think about it yeah yeah
that was the centerfold it was just all
it was completely nude faces
so anyways keep an eye out later this
week
we hope to be able to unveil my design
the better design for the break room mug
uh tommy's hopefully we'll never see the
line and once my team of lawyers
communicates with zach immediately at
the end of this episode we will be
unveiling my mug only to all of you and
you will decide which mug mine being the
only one available is the supreme mug
until then we will simply drink out of
bowls like the dogs that we are got to
be the dog
from mug weekly apparently blew out some
here in trump
sorry guys
i've been telling people for years to
watch this show on mute why didn't you
throw away the old mugs though that's my
problem well i actually went outside and
played a little game i called knock
knock smash
when i knocked on our neighbor's door
and smash a mug and run away oh okay he
comes out and goes not again
and he has to clean up he has to clean
up and i watch him sweep up the bug and
then i do the best prank ever dude yeah
i did it for 18 hours
saturday that's a lot of mugs i'm
it's a on
exhausted i got very badly sunburned
uh hey speaking of sunburned or feeling
burned or feeling ripped off what's
going on with the super cats guys
we all just did we buy too many heart
cells we saw that we almost killed
yeah i feel bad guys okay i will uh i
will commit to this if we spin the wheel
and silly string comes up again
i will take silly string to the face
eyes open mouth open oh my gosh
my neck's really burning
you mentioned that you had an allergic
reaction i went oh no you must feel bad
and then you turn towards
[Applause]
uh yeah yeah yeah i know what you're
talking about what the hell is it my my
sister
epipen my sister works at a va hospital
where she helps sick uh veterans and i i
take silly strings to the face you
should go in there and say that you have
a serious hey guys we lost zach today he
died he died in combat silly cop
don't we have some geology creams or
something that can soothe you they're
not sponsoring us this week sorry i've
got a song it's time for mandatory five
oh no
i'm back baby it's mandatory fun
the world's most popular segment as
voted on by you
the stupid viewers of this show
each week i gather three of my closest
dearest friends and i sign them
to secrecy
i make them sign ndas about what happens
here but then
we show it on air
and our pre-taped episodes are there
every day don't know if it's pre-taped
unfortunately
no my doctor dr nasty
just paged me and let me know that they
had actually a mongoose just died of
natural causes they're going to be able
to put the they're going to put the
mongoose cartilage in between my knees
to give me a mongoose's dexterity they
didn't have tiny legs
[Laughter]
no it's all the little weights
goes into one knee yeah it's 15
mongooses oh wow
i poisoned what happened is i poisoned a
flock of mongooses last night and now
they're monkeys monkeys yeah i actually
think it's mongesians
uh
mongodb but it's not about that guys
it's about mandatory fun i do have
someone that can fill in
him uh he is pretty far away though so
if you guys need his vampires
because i the master of mad libs oh god
who is this man i am the master of mad
libs and today
we will be doing mad libs on the show
whimsical mad libs words that make
stories silly oh normal stories are too
boring for the breakfast master of mad
libs are you from like a scandinavian
country i'm from no i'm from
long beach california yeah
i just have a curiosity for hats
haberdashery is my passion my second
passion is goofy madly
okay okay now we all know megan v
stallion took the cameo world by storm
with her cameo on she-hulk it was
twerkalicious
it was
uh the right side of the law if you look
at the crimes that were committed i do
believe she was justified now in
retaining she-hulk services
but there are more cameos afoot oh in
the mcu pipeline of course
uh and zach i'm going to go with you
first can you give me the name of a
singer
the name of a singer well topical harry
styles oh
harry styles already appeared in the mcu
uh can you give me a noun
um
uh
poison
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay and finally
can you give me an animal
um well
mongoose
all right wow feels like you didn't
really let the creative juices overflow
his brain is damaging are you just
naming things like brick he's going
through a medical emergency all right
well this one is particularly goofy or
mad if you will
following megan v
stallion's cameo on she-hulk we now know
that harry styles
will be making a yet unknown cameo in
the disney plus series iron heart
sources say harry was spotted on set
wearing a green rash
and a large mongoose skin jacket next
mad lib wow
angelica you're up next okay i'm ready
um
can you give me the name of a reality tv
star
um
kim kardashian okay is that count kim k
is oh that counts i don't think we would
list her as a regular actor no
can you give me a noun
a noun toilet
oh no
this is going to be mad
all right and a verb a verb um
it's working
nice
i was also primed for this
okay
this is going to be in
freaking sane oh no
brmz the hottest celebrity god central
has the scoop that kim kardashian will
be playing mo man in the new fantastic
four the star reportedly gained 40
toilets for the roll
and gave up twerking in order to star in
the film
next she gave up 40. 40 toilets brandon
final host driven mad lib but perhaps
we'll let the chat do one
disposal
brandon give me the name of an athlete
an athlete uh jackie joyner kersey nice
my that's famous
famous olympic athlete
track and field star
jackie joyner kersey
cousin or sister of flo joe i believe
gone
too soon
yeah i believe so maybe sister-in-law
maybe they married the same man if
you're listening call in please call me
an x-man an x-man uh uh uh
morph
whoa deep cut
give me an adjective
um
uh how about a feeling oh a feeling uh
despondent
ooh
it's a good word i'm glad i don't have
to show how i'm spelling these words
and finally finally a verb they're just
round faces
a verb all right it just says kill tommy
masticating masticating
okay okay
oh boy
he spelled that one
the mad trains coming into station
welcome to the depot next stop madville
marvel studios can confirm that jackie
joyner kersey will play the role of
morph in the upcoming beautifully
awaited film
the marvels
i feel absolutely despondent about the
role
that's actually pretty funny they had to
bring her back from the dead i've been
dreaming about masticating into acting
for a long time she's alive jackie
joey
jackie jenner i believe apologies to the
jacket but come on the show come on the
show jackie joyner all right now uh okay
never mind almost read something that
would have just really opened up a can
of worms oh no this one's going to the
chat this one's going to the chat
and i'm just going to probably read the
first one chat give me a famous dead
person
famous dead person famous dead person
this dead person we're only on like a 30
minute delay right
famous dead person well you should just
like list everything you need from them
i need a famous dead person i need an
avenger
oh and i need an animal well that's
coming in j swizzy did send in a super
chat saying today's my birthday and all
i want is a shout out from the break
room i love you guys i'm sorry we can't
do that j swizzy we absolutely refused
uh we got george washington elvis
michael jackson oh they're coming in
fast bruce lee i like bruce
i'm going bruce okay bruce lee is a
winner nice bruce lee all right now an
avenger an avenger
to the avengers i see captain america i
see
vision thor spider-man spider hawkeye
heath ledger falcon quick ledger
anteater oh that's the animal
okay
uh antelope i saw antelope i see billy
mays billy mays
some of these might be um uh famous dead
people charlotte from charlotte's web
hope again
i read jack of hearts almost do another
f in there made my own
okay
okay that's it all right well this one
takes place
in the future isn't that mad
time can be played with in mad libs
d23 gave us tons of news but none more
shocking than bruce lee returning to
earth from the grave to play hawkeye
from earth 838 when asked to comment
bruce lee opened his mouth and a wasp
flew out
because he's a corpse
he's a ghoul
thank you madeline master yeah thank you
master of matter no problem let me
return
to my prison cell yeah
great to be on the outside it was a
crime against canada well uh longer wait
for tommy to return uh ron sortino had a
great i'm back oh okay tommy's back out
of the knees time no c yeah
unfortunately when i got there the
mongooses had turned wow
like they'd gone sour
no they've they changed religions oh
okay yeah yeah yeah
mongooses are all scientologists now oh
that's too bad they don't believe in
organ donation
ron sortino in the super chat said i'm
loving she-hulk not gonna lie i have no
idea who megan the stallion is that
being said when mark lynn baker appeared
that cameo was everything he's a sitcom
legend can we get a perfect stranger
she-hulk parody shirt
ron i love you my dude what a great how
many the the uh
this concentric circles of people who
don't know who meg and the stallion are
but do recognize cousin larry from
perfect strangers i mean you're right in
between that intersection right it was
great too i hope we get more
if you've never heard of megan the
stallion
how nice for you you've got some great
youtube videos you can go watch right
now for the very first time if you have
children in the house yeah some great
youtubers these are these are for late
night just just run runtime what power
did you decide on for macon by the way
we had a lot of discussions about it
yeah a lot of it was like the ability to
like hypnotize people
with her like music almost like a jiggly
puff you know whatever or a dazzler yeah
obviously a lot of quake references
because of her booty shaking oh okay
quake uh people saying that like she
could hypnotize people with her music to
force them to twerk like that's all
that's all she could do she's going to
work
you cannot resist the urge to twerk at
the end of the day i think we can all
agree that the power that she would
carry most deeply into the mcu would be
the healing powers of jesus christ oh
are you gonna say maybe moisture related
part powers oh well there was some there
was someone saying that she has the
ability to cause severe hydration i make
you thirsty oh okay very clever
responses from
your dehydration if you're thirsty right
yeah then she can rehydrate she can
really she has the power to control
people yeah pretty much
and the theory that she was just a god
from like another dimension that's a
good i like that just coming in here
living it up
lore all that is to say ron sortino
is a banger she's got like nine bangers
man she's got a lot of good songs look
him up my man uh chrissy joskey in the
super chat saying beaver now one could
argue
chrissy trying to participate in the mad
lab i'm going to argue chris just wanted
to shout before all caps
sometimes too honestly
there's nothing wrong with that ron if
you're up late on the internet also look
up uh gordon lightfoot wreck of the
edmond fitzgerald
i think i guarantee ron knows gordon
might put okay ron how many gordon
lightfoot albums do you own i got two on
wax oh
he's got the guess who he's got um
all these guys aren't crying about that
all the canadian greats uh i'm just
assuming you're canadian right uh funky
monkey said agents of shield is nothing
more than a live-action what-if episode
what if coulson
didn't die oh
that's a good that's a really good
technically he did die and then they
rebuilt him
against his weapon oh that's right yes
it is an interesting way of looking at
that i think there was another
interesting super chat
uh creek show saying here's 20 bucks go
wash up nope the damage is already done
uh film juice how dare you film juice i
told you never to show up at this show
again okay you're you're persona non
grata film juice wow okay when i'm on
this show you can't be in the chat whoa
my mortal enemy film juice oh
come on man don't antagonize him like
this he's dying every now everything
looks
gonna start spreading i got a freaking
grayscale
dog
silly stroller that's right this has
turned into a telethon we need every
dime he got to get zach well okay we're
19 away from spinning the wheel and
turning his whole face
you won't like when he's silly
multiple tubes of cortisone are gonna be
needed to cure whatever the hell's
happening on my neck um there was
another super chat i forgot who put it
in there
uh oh yeah oh that's braddock asking our
thoughts on killmonger coming back in
black panther uh eric among other people
has pointed out there are some angles in
that first trailer
you know where it looks like oh that's a
leg could that be killmonger in the
black panther suit right i mean i
i hope they don't like revive 616
killmonger like i like the idea that
he's dead it happened there's that but
you could bring in a killmonger from
like a variant right okay who comes to
our universe i like that i thought there
was talks about um conflicts with
scheduling
it could be oh it might be yeah just to
come up with this from this that would
be a great
stop
yeah michael b jordan's an incredibly
busy guy he's like directs he acts a lot
eat but he's got a creed moving in joe
you gotta imagine he'd make a little
time well like jonathan mages is in
creed three oh michael b jordan what if
creed three is not a real movie yeah
what is that oh
that's the working title
um somebody tells stallone because i
think he's freaking out he doesn't
really have his credit you know
sure if creed3 is real it's simulu
simulu come on the moon why would you
know get over here because he's a hug he
knows everything yeah see we'll bring
dick cavett yeah
get over here
still alive
kevin's still alive
from his fifth nap of the day and get
him to the break if you don't know who
megan the stallion is you know who did
kavanagh yeah that's right that's a
guarantee we're doing the rest of the
show for ron shapiro or whatever his
name was
it's by tina
uh my dude john sortino sartino ryan
come on the show my man
we're gonna do a full boomer episode of
this show where it's it's nothing about
iranian contractor americans
it's all about tiffany at the mall with
debbie gibson i know you got creams in
that medicine cabinet bring your creams
heal my boy
we'll give you a mug you gotta you got a
poultice you could use on me man maybe
like uh
what kind of leeching you're into right
yeah you ever do bloodletting
on that note uh we're gonna we're gonna
wrap up here again check out new rocks
actually all four of us are repping some
different new rock stars merch um check
out new rockstarsmerch.com
where again someday this week
mugs
hopefully will be available can i get
something other than a bowl yeah we got
to get some mugs in here
you can yeah it's either bowls or plates
and it's a lot harder to drink on this
tree
i like a sip maybe we can find
alternative objects for tomorrow but uh
thank you all for watching nina you
slipping in there at the end um
uh do you think they are turning the
manga about wolverine called snicked
into an animated series it's by tsutsumu
nihei
i don't know i think it'd be interesting
they haven't announced other animated
mcu things beyond what if they're gonna
expand 97. if they're gonna do anything
in the style of like manga or anime
please do it animated let's stop doing
the live-action anime i don't think it's
working you're playing i like this i
don't know if we can go out i like to
make a practice so close
i know you know what carla day i'm just
here for zach thank you carla i think we
owe it to carla and the other trash bags
let's do one more wheel spin all right
we'll spin let's go out on the wheel
spin tommy are you going to spin the
wheel just turn it i'll spin the wheel
but i won't lie
i hope you get 10 minutes of silence
is that one of the options no but it
would be
tommy don't break the one i want to
thank my mom and my dad i want to say
shout out to my beautiful
nobodies
okay one more spin
go go i want to thank uh satan i want to
thank the band the monkeys satan walked
out oh god tommy hulk out on what
thursday night
sorry
put my microphone
thursday night the buffalo bills invade
the city of angels with a demonic
presence known as josh allen's right arm
we're gonna take the rams and turn them
into the hams and take a bite into that
ham sandwich and throw it in the ground
hulk love the buffalo bills hulk need
buffalo bills i forgot supposed to be
hulking out home love josh allen floyd
to gabe davis throwing to stefan diggs
throwing to jake kumaro throwing to
isaac mckenzie isaiah mckenzie i hope
forget the first name of mckenzie dawson
knox hulk the love dawson knocks bro to
dawson knox hulk club linebacker cora
milano
edmonds hufflepuff strong safety yeah
thank you oh thank you
wow
yes if you're at so fight stadium on
thursday uh look out for tommy uh
literally look out for him he might be
coming off the top rope into a table oh
uh also shout out to glad to be king
what do you guys think about titania
joining the thunderbolts i like that's
the first time hearing of that i like
that as a concept for me vs 300 saying
hawkeye is the best avenger oh you might
be on a lonely island there my man three
prometheus 300 i don't know um with that
we we got to get out of here thank you
brandon barrick angelica trey tommy
bechtold thank you mad lib master thank
you all in the chat we'll be back
tomorrow live on the break room
[Music]
[Music]
you